I got a question before we leave
okay so we don't charge people right for
podcasters we've never done that we'll
be turning down money and [__] I've
never taken money yeah like is that a
thing like on from from your airport
okay now I don't think it's a thing
amongst like the platforms that are
respectable okay okay cool there are
definitely platforms that are
I don't think have high integrity okay
okay my thing is if my co-sign's worth
like like if you could pay me for my
cosign what's my co-sign Worth right
right it's like you know what I'm saying
right right no I've turned down a lot of
money
no what is it like it's a sponsor
sponsorship that's different oh yeah
well we sponsored up over here right
right shout out to hardine shout out to
King Kong shout out to Bluetooth Odd
Socks we got my Odd Socks right there
all right LRG clothing that's right who
else is sponsoring the podcast these
days my bookie if you want to gamble
yeah I mean listen y'all watch the
commercials you know right right no I'll
take the sponsorship but you can't pay
me to get on my [__] right right right
right right yeah cause we don't do that
either I'll do favors like if somebody I
know hits me and I respect them and
they're like hey I just signed this kid
he's dope can he come on the show I'd be
like Kenny Freestyle right right A lot
of times it's like the more up and
coming like raw talent I have them do
the freestyle thing okay okay okay
because it doesn't you know the
interview might not make sense okay okay
but I'll do favors right right but I
won't I won't um I haven't taken money
now right I figure if that's the
difference listen there was a small
point in time though where I was on a
terrible gambling binge
I was down like 30k and I remember
telling my boy David I said man I might
just start taking somebody
it's the only time I thought about it
right the New York Jets beat the Bengals
in like week seven with Mike White as
the starting quarterback and I lost like
15 grand and I was like
yeah gambling is bad
yeah thank God it's not legal well look
it doesn't matter we're actually
gambling isn't terrible if you go to my
bookie and use the promo code bootleg
and you sign up and uh
yeah I'm a user you know
Nano he's a [__] Gambler gotta love
it I don't know well anyway I appreciate
you pulling up man I appreciate that
[__] King boom